[Música]
qué tienen en común los mejores magos de
la historia a todos los que tenemos en
la cabeza y los mejores empresarios o
empresarias que también nos vienen a la
mente no pues mucho más de lo que os
podríais imaginar mucho más yo en toda
mi trayectoria profesional y también en
todos los años que llevo estudiando lo
que es mi gran pasión que es el arte de
la magia me doy cuenta de que existe un
paralelismo impresionante
interesantísimo entre los dos mundos el
mundo de los negocios y el mundo de la
magia y yo creo además que los grandes
directivos eso es que todos como he
dicho antes tenemos en mente
probablemente sin saberlo han estado
utilizando los grandes secretos las
bases de los grandes secretos del
sionismo que todos los magos utilizan
para sorprender su audiencias y alcanzar
el éxito
sin romper mi código mágico voy a
revelar los dos de esos secretos y
además con un efecto mágico que llevamos
preparando más de un año voy a intentar
sorprenderlos y rememorar ese imposible
y alcanzar ese éxito del que hoy vamos a
hablar y para eso necesito tan solo dos
cosas una que no dejéis de prestar
atención a esta caja es una caja fuerte
yo tengo la llave aquí en mi bolsillo y
no me voy a acercar a ella hasta el
final y segundo punto contar con la
ayuda de la presentadora por ejemplo que
tenemos un instrumento si puedes
acercarte aquí nos vamos a acercar mucho
entre los dos
antes de nada una premisa muy importante
es que todo el mundo sepa que tú y yo no
nos conocemos no nos hemos visto es una
premisa necesaria porque si no en el
mundo de la magia nada tendría sentido
fijaos hoy vamos a jugar a ser grandes
directivos por un día hoy te vas a ser
una empresaria que es lo que le gustaría
tener a una empresaria en la mente bueno
que te gustaría tener la capacidad de
saber cuándo va a ocurrir un gran
acontecimiento tecnológico industrial
empresarial para estar ahí en primera
línea y aprovecharse en primera
instancia de lo que va a ocurrir sacarle
el máximo partido pues bien yo con la
ayuda de ayudante por aquí tengo una
urna con 78 pelotas divididas coge la
puedes cogerla sí sí
gracias del año 22 al año 99 o sea cada
una de esas pelotas que son del 22 al 99
simbolizan un año de aquí del 2022 92 al
quiero que remueva las pelotas que veas
que son todas diferentes que no hay
ninguna que pese más que otra que no hay
dobles fondos y cuando tú quieras pues
coge dos de ellas
las tienes cuáles son números 34 y 74 34
y 74 en una de ellas que va a simbolizar
un año de este próximo centenario de
este centenario quiero que elijas una de
ellas y ocurrirá algo grandioso en el
mundo de la empresa con cuál te quieres
quedar en 34 el 34 estás seguro se lo
digo porque esta noche cuando tú vayas a
casa y vayan a la cama vas a pensar que
hubiera pensado si hubiera elegido el 74
se va a producir mucho asombro pues está
segura de verdad se siente perfecto pues
muchas gracias el número 34 todo el
mundo que está aquí todo el mundo que
está en casa que tenga clara la fecha
del año 34 2034 pero todo ocurre en un
momento de la historia y en un lugar
concreto de la historia por eso yo
traigo aquí también una bola del mundo
con 194 países que son los que están
identificados por la onu vale y quiero
que le des vueltas a la bola del mundo
quiero que veas que es una bola real que
son todos los países diferentes darle
vueltas y cuando tú quieras te paras y
pones tu yema del dedo sobre uno de los
dos países desde los países de sol qué
[Música]
tengas tu mano no tu quieras si cae
entre 23 eliges el que tú quieras lo
tienes cual colorado colorado eeuu el
estado de colorado seguro quieres
cambiar por un país no sé por pakistán
por senegal
te doy esa oportunidad
eso es demasiado obvio si de verdad si
es que la gente no se lo va a creer una
provincia de españa a la que tú quieras
coruña coruña coruña perfecto algo
maravilloso va a ocurrir en el mundo de
los negocios en el año 34 en coruña si
lo dejamos ahí perfecto pues ya te
puedes entrar muchas gracias y contiguo
al final si alcalde presentar o se lo
recoge es perfecto año 34 en coruña
bueno ya ahora sí vamos a la chicha
cuáles son esos dos puntos de los que ha
hablado que tienen en común el mundo de
los negocios y el mundo corporativo
número uno el poder de la anticipación
que es la anticipación la anticipación
es preparación es conciencia es
paciencia es un claro conocimiento del
entorno
en el arte la anticipación tenemos por
un lado el mundo de la magia en el que
no se imagina es como anticipan los
magos los trucos que van a hacer
se preparan miles de horas todo lo que
acontece luego en el escenario
ensayan con sus manos conocen las
medidas de los escenarios es increíble
un caso por ejemplo david copperfield de
ubicó perfil que todos conocéis el gran
truco en el que él volaba por el
escenario y que luego pasaba por unos
aros ese truco junto con su equipo
técnico tardó en desarrollarse más de
seis años e increíble hasta que vio la
luz y luego aseguraba unos pocos
segundos
en el mundo de la magia pero en el mundo
de los negocios es fundamental anticipar
sobre todo para evitar riesgos por
ejemplo todos conocemos los casos de
kodak de blockbuster sobre estos últimos
y seguro que todos aquí tenéis netflix
es sabéis que los fundadores más
randolph y red hastings en un momento
dado y esto lo podéis ver en internet
porque esta entrevista volaron a dallas
para intentar vender su empresa por 50
millones de dólares y sabéis lo que pasó
que se rieron de ellos es increíble ayer
por la noche vi que la capitalización
bursátil de netflix rondaba los 243 mil
millones dólares claramente no
anticiparon lo que podía venir pero si
hay una persona en el mundo de los
negocios que anticipa las escenas mejor
que nadie y que a mí me apasiona es este
hombre por un lado de mi comentario este
es david rockefeller porque feller era
un famoso empresario estadounidense
todos lo tenéis en la cabeza y fijaos
este hombre tenía un tarjetero fichero
con 100 mil tarjetas de visita en esas
tarjetas de visita apuntaba desde los
nombres de primeros ministros presidente
eeuu grandes empresarios hasta botones
de hoteles
en ellos en esas tarjetitas cuando él
volvía a casa apuntaba a algo que le
había llamado la atención desencuentro
que había tenido pues estado con su
esposa al lado de la universidad de su
hijo y tiempo después seis meses un año
dos años cuando se volvía a encontrar
con esas personas él rescataba esos
ficheros las tarjetas de visita y volvía
a poner la conversación algo que se
había comentado en el pasado eso le
permitía generar una familiaridad brutal
con aquellos con los que se encontraba y
le permitía cerrar muchos negocios
el poder la anticipación en la magia y
en el mundo los negocios y el punto
número 2 el poder de la atención la
atención a mí me maravilla cuando
hablamos de atención en el mundo de la
magia hablamos de un concepto que es mil
dã direction que quiere decir mis la
dirección
es la dirección quiere decir atraer la
mirada hacia un punto concreto para
desviar la atención de lo importante lo
que va a pasar en otro sitio y que
ocurra el engaño fijaos en este cuadro
de atribuido al bosque de 1.502 se llama
el prestidigitador no no es que los
magos intenten engañar y robar a las
personas que tienen delante pero este es
un claro ejemplo de cómo desviar la
atención con unos juegos de manos
mientras una ayudante pues le roba la
cartera a otra de las personas que está
justo viendo el espectáculo y esto lo
voy a demostrar yo fijaos lo voy a
demostrar claramente para que lo veáis
aquí en vivo y en directo tengo una
moneda un dólar americana ya que estaba
hablando de rockefeller para que lo vea
claramente la cámara fijaos una moneda
si yo esta moneda la cojo con la mano
izquierda llevo mi mirada hacia ella y
además la alejó un poco del punto donde
ha nacido claramente vuestra atención
está aquí tiempo necesario el que ocurre
para que la magia acontezca y aparezcan
dos monedas esto se puede repetir si
fijaos las dos monedas en la mano
izquierda y ahora cojo yo con la mano
derecha
una de ellas y con esta floritura ya ha
pasado el tiempo suficiente para que la
magia ocurra de nuevo y en esta mano
donde tú antes prestaba su atención
la otra manera haya desaparecido y os
preguntaréis esto se puede repetir una
tercera vez sí pero teniendo en cuenta
los patrones de comportamiento del ser
humano y hacia donde presta atención si
yo era la moneda me la pongo la mano
izquierda
y soplo desaparece pero eso lo hay
de todos los sitios para que siento dos
pasos antes la macro ocurra
y bueno esto es el poder la atención en
el mundo de la magia pero en el mundo de
los negocios os llamaría también la
atención la importancia que tiene este
aspecto
goleman decía en un artículo de la
harvard business review que la atención
era la base del liderazgo efectivo la
atención a uno mismo a los demás y al
entorno que le rodea
sabéis que en esta mujer esta mujer es
mi gartner me encanta esta historia esta
es la madre de bill gates y organizó una
cena en la que se conocieron por primera
vez bill gates y warren buffett y cuando
estaba todo el mundo la cena a los
invitados en un momento dado
y me preguntó de todos los que estáis
aquí si tuvierais que decir cuál ha sido
la clave del éxito en vuestra vida cuál
dirías que ha sido y warren buffett y
bill gates contestaron la misma palabra
focus lo que es lo mismo atención
ponerlo con algo en unas pocas cosas
como lo que hemos visto ahora de la
magia para que no te engañen para sacar
el máximo rendimiento y estos son los
puntos podríamos hablar de muchos más
hoy no da tiempo tenemos otros otros
nexos no que hay en común entre el mundo
de la magia el mundo los negocios
podríamos hablar del poder de la
comunicación la creatividad el pensar
diferente el tener planes vez salidas
múltiples por salir más las cosas
incluso la propia suerte que juega un
papel fundamental en ambos mundos
si tienes todos estos factores en común
garantiza sus 100% del éxito pues el
100% del éxito no lo sé lo que sí que sé
es que viendo a estos grandes tan solo
parándose a pensar en ello y empezando
los a poner en práctica aunque sólo sea
un poco pueden empezar a ocurrir cosas
inimaginables cosas que no habríamos
esperado nunca que pasarán y hablando de
cosas inimaginables yo no sé si habéis
dejado de prestar atención a esta caja
que está aquí yo tengo aquí bueno voy a
poner el mando aquí porque ya no lo
necesito
tengo aquí la llave
de esta caja
bueno antes la voy a colocar sí gracias
o no aquí está bien la voy a colocar en
la mesa y la voy a poner aquí en medio
para que lo vea todo el mundo porque no
quiero que os perdáis nada fijaos la voy
a abrir por primera vez porque a mí hace
un año cuando me dijeron que tenía que
dar esta charla te bueno pues no se me
curso es mejor idea que anticipar un
pensamiento no
y pensar en algo que podría ocurrir que
pudiera maravillar a los que estáis aquí
ya los que no están viendo en casa
y en esta caja
guarde
guarde un papel
con una predicción
vamos a ver en esta predicción lo que
tenemos por aquí
la predicción tenemos números me
encantan los números yo soy ingeniero
ves aquí tu número en qué año estábamos
pensando en el 34 verdad bueno si
hubiera estado aquí el 34 pues habría
sido bastante chulo porque oye al final
tenía una una posibilidad entre 80 yo
creo que es algo más de un 1% habría
sido maravilloso
y con esto acabó fijaos qué ocurre si
rememoramos al físico rodinger nou una
frase que a mí me maravilla y que dice
así nuestra tarea en el mundo no
consiste en ver lo que nos ha visto
antes sino en pensar lo que nunca se ha
pensado sólo elegimos todos los días
fijaos qué ocurre si empezamos a sumar
la primera línea 8 + 11 19 + 14 30 y 31
34 y la segunda línea 13 215 7 22 más 12
34 y la tercera 3 + 16 19 29 28 6 34 10
+ 5 15 4 19 + 15 34 y la vertical sería
imposible 8 + 13 21 3 24 10 34 11 2 13
16 29 las 5 34 y la tercera 14 7 24 34 y
la última 1 + 12 30
pero no sólo eso la diagonal 82 10 + 9
19 15 34 y la otra diagonal 17 8 16 más
10 34 pero no sólo eso
fijaos si sumamos las esquinas 8 + 19 15
24 10 34 y si sumamos estos dos
cuadrantes estos dos 12 618 + 3 de 21 13
34 y el del medio 2 799 18 + 16 34 y es
que la magia puede ocurrir pero no sólo
esto hemos dicho que algo maravilloso
ocurriría en el año 34 y hoy quiero
estar con vosotros
algún acontecimiento tecnológico
industrial para estar allí en primera
persona pero como diría rockefeller
porque no vernos en persona
y formar una historia de negocios juntos
así que nos vemos en a coruña muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]